boire un verre tout en chinant dans une
ambiance rétro c'est un concept original
qu'on peut retrouver à pont-levoire
Christine oui c'est l'idée d'un
loir-et-cherien qui a ouvert une
brocante bistrot ça s'appelle les 30
glorieuses le principe du lieu c'est à
la fois un bar et un vide-grenier en
quelque sorte les Turquie la visite pour
vous
[Musique]
ambiance rétro vinyle et objets
le tout un verre à la main bienvenue au
30 glorieuses d'abord brocante et
maintenant aussi bistrot c'est un
concept unique en Touraine une idée
soufflée par des adeptes de ce lieu ou
en couleur j'ai des clients qui sont qui
sont passés et qui vont dire on
prendrait bien un petit thé l'ambiance
est sympa on a envie de se poser dans
dans ce lieu un peu atypique
du coup l'idée à germer dans la tête et
donc depuis juillet dernier les verres
pleins se confondent avec les vides au
menu du bar des produits locaux
uniquement tous proviennent des environs
dans un rayon maximum de 60 km autour du
commerce
une surface de 300 mètres carrés avec
plus d'un millier d'articles la partie
brocante elle est ouverte depuis deux
ans pour Raphaël le gérant c'est la
concrétisation d'un rêve d'enfants
chiner le dimanche matin déjà j'ai
toujours été passionné par les années
50-60 un moment donné dans ma vie
professionnelle je me suis posé et je me
suis demandé ce que je pouvais faire et
c'est là en fait que ce rêve de môme a
resurgi et maintenant ça fait quatre ans
que je suis brocanteur les 30 glorieuses
proposent des animations tous les
vendredis soirs rendez-vous à la
brocante bistrot sur la route de
Montrichard dans la commune de Pontlevoy